what is the best way to make Prince
Harry squirm well apparently all you got
to do is just bring up his new Hollywood
girlfriend last night in Antigua prime
minister Gaston Brown reportedly
embarrassed Harry at a gala event saying
quote I believe we are expecting a new
princess soon I want you to know that
you are very welcome to come on your
honeymoon here Harry said to have
grimaced and avoided eye contact during
the remarks but at other times he was
smiling and seemed to enjoy himself and
is Megan speaking out about their
fairytale relationship and an essay for
Elle UK she writes quote with fame comes
opportunity but it also includes a
responsibility to advocate and share to
focus less on glass slippers and more on
pushing through glass ceilings are you
blushing
I never blush our USA series suits just
wrapped this six season and her co-star
Sarah Rafferty seemed to be trying to
preserve Megan's privacy at an Emmy
event in New York well I don't comment
on my castmates personal lives but of
course it's very exciting and I'm very
happy for her and while we're watching
to see if Megan arrives in the Caribbean
to be with Harry we sat down with her
sister Samantha oh my God look at her
glow and look at her go and she's just
amazing and this relationship is giving
her a lot of that I am so amazed and
thrilled at the woman you've become and
I love you proud of you
Samantha grant is sixteen years older
than Megan
they have different mothers but both
were up with the same father who is an
Emmy winning Hollywood lighting director
grin says she's not jealous of Megan's
Fame and believes her words were twisted
when she spoke to a reporter about a
past family issue so there was a little
incident where Megan eyes sort of took
different sides i sided with my dad she
sided with her mom but the only remark
that I made was about and just a
disagreement five or six years ago
within the family one word spun into
about 30 other dramatic words you know
pushy princess diva narcissistic all of
this other stuff came out that I never
said
the sisters have drifted apart recently
but spoke on the phone just last year
she's concerned that false stories about
their family will hurt Megan and her
oriole relationship it's really just
time for privacy this stuff has to stop